THE SECOND MONTH IN A ROW ABOVE
200,000.
>> John: BIG NUMBERS FOR AUGUST.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FACING
LEGAL CHALLENGE.
ARIZONA ON TUESDAY BECOMING
FIRST STATE IN THE NATION TO
FILE A LAWSUIT IN FEDERAL COURT.
NEWS COMES AS RECENT POLLS SHOW
THE PUBLIC MAY BE LOSING FAITH
IN THE ADMINISTRATION’S ABILITY
TO HANDLE THE PANDEMIC.
ATTORNEY GENERAL MARK BRNOVICH
JOINS US NOW.
THE CASE BETWEEN BRNOVICH IS
EQUAL PROTECTION ARGUMENT.
YOU SAY UNDER EQUAL PROTECTION
CLAUSE, VACCINE MANDATE IS NULL
AND VOID BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE THAT MIGRANTS WHO ARE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY, WE SAW 208,000 WITH
NEW NUMBERS IN AUGUST, MAKE THE
CASE FOR US THAT BECAUSE IT
DOESN’T APPLY TO MIGRANTS, THE
WHOLE THING NEEDS TO BE VOIDED.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON,
JOHN.
IT IS QUITE FRANKLY AS SIMPLE AS
THIS, I DON’T THINK WE CAN HAVE
A SERIOUS DISCUSSION ON COVID
THAT DOESN’T BEGIN WITH TALKING
ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON AT OUR
BORDER.
IT DEMONSTRATES HYPOCRISY OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WHICH HAS
A GREAT EFFECT ON US.
THEY SAID, IF YOU ARE A
NON-CITIZEN, YOU HAVE OPTION TO
TAKE THE VACCINE OR NOT, A U.S.
CITIZEN WILL BE REQUIRED TO TAKE
THE VACCINE.
THAT VIOLATES EQUAL PROTECTION
CLAUSE.
SECONDLY, IMPORTANT TO
EMPHASIZE, IF YOU READ OUR
LAWSUIT, WE MAKE THE CASE THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF DOES NOT HAVE
ANY POWER, ANYWHERE IN THE
CONSTITUTION, ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU CONSIDER THE NINTH AND TENTH
AMENDMENT TO MANDATE ANYBODY
ANYWHERE SHOULD GET THE VACCINE.
FROM JUMP STREET, OUR POSITION
THIS IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
EXERCISE OF POLICE POWER AS
PRESIDENT DOESN’T HAVE AND
FURTHERMORE, IF HE COULD, HE’S
DOING IN SUCH A WAY CONTRARY TO
CONSTITUTION, GIVES PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY, PASS, OPTION TO TAKE
IT AND FORCING U.S. CITIZENS TO
TAKE IT, THAT SHOWS HYPOCRISY IN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> John: PARAGRAPH 12, THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT A KING WHO CAN
EXERCISE THIS UNBRIDLED POWER
UNILATERALRY
UNILATERALLY AND EVEN GEORGE III
WOULD NOT HAVE HAD ROYAL DECREE
ALONE.
YOU ARE CLAIMING IT IS ONE OF A
SERIES, GREATER SERIES OF
CONSTITUTIONALLY INAPPROPRIATE
ACTIONS.
>> JOHN, THERE IS A CASE IN THE
FIFTH CIRCUIT CAN STOP BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FROM HALTING
DEPORTATIONS.
WE SAID FEDERAL LOSS HAVE TO
DEPORT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DEPORTATION ORDERS.
THEY WERE NOT DOING.
THERE ARE SERIES OF ACTIONS AND
WHETHER NATIONALIZING ELECTION,
MASSIVE TAX BILLS THAT ARE BOON
DOGGLES, FOR GREEN ENERGY
CAUSES, WE HAVE SEEN ATTEMPT TO
CONSOLIDATE POWER IN D.C.
I SUBMIT TO YOU ISSUE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOESN’T HAVE
POWER, HAVE YOU ENABLERS IN
CONGRESS ALLOWING BIDEN TO DO IT
AND CONTRADICTORY TO THE
CONSTITUTION AND SOMETHING I
THINK THAT IS UNPRECEDENTED.
THINK ABOUT THIS, JOHN, NOTION
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THE
PRESIDENT CAN ORDER YOU TO
INJECT SOMETHING IN YOUR BODY
AND REGARDLESS WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THE VACCINE, GOOD, BAD,
DOESN’T MATTER, IT IS PRINCIPLE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, ONE MAN,
ONE PERSON CANNOT TAKE CONTROL
OF YOUR BODY AND TELL YOU WHAT
YOU HAVE TO PUT INSIDE IT.
THESE ARE FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES
WE ARE FIGHTING FOR AND I HOPE
FOLKS SEE THAT.
I WORRY ABOUT POLITICIZATION OF
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, I WILL
KEEP FIGHTING.
>> John: THIS IS BEFORE THE
COURT, FEDERAL COURTS, IT WILL
BE UP TO THE THIRD BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE DETERMINATION
IF THIS IS CONSTITUTIONALLY
SOUND OR NOT.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" HOLMAN
JENKINS WROTE ABOUT THIS
YESTERDAY SAYING THE GOOD NEWS
ABOUT THE JOE BIDEN VACCINE
MANDATE, LAWYERS AND JUDGES WILL
HAVE BOTH INSENTIVE AND DUTY TO
APPLY CLEAR THINKING ABOUT
COVID, WHICH HAS BEEN LACKING.
THE QUESTION IS NOT WHETHER
VACCINES ARE GOOD OR BAD, BUT
WHETHER THE GOVERNMENT HAS
SUFFICIENT AUTHORITY AND GROUNDS
TO OVERRULE PERSONAL CHOICE AND
WHETHER TO TAKE THEM.
TOO, ATTORNEY GENERAL BRNOVICH,
THE TREND LINE FOR JOE BIDEN IS
GOING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
THE NEW QUINNIPIAC POLL, 48% OF
RESPOND
RESPONDENTS APPROVE OF HOW HE IS
HANDLING IT, WELL WITHIN THE
MARGIN OF ERROR, THE TREND LINE
GOING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> JOHN, I HAVE A PUBLIC SCHOOL
KID, I DIDN’T GO TO IVY LEAGUE
SCHOOL, BUT I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE, MY FAMILY FLED
COMMUNISM, MAKING SURE THERE IS
RULE OF LAW IN A GOVERNMENT,
ESPECIALLY PRESIDENT THAT
RESPECTS THE CONSTITUTION.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ISSUES, IF
YOU ALLOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO GET AWAY WITH
THIS, IT IS UNFETTERED AMOUNT OF
POWER IN THE HANDS OF ONE
PERSON, ANY ONE ADMIN STRAGSZ ST
6789 I /* /* -- ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS INVASION OF OUR BODIES
AND RIGHT TO PRIVACY AND
OVERREACH BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IF YOU ALLOW THIS PRECEDENT TO
FAN, ALLOW THE PRESIDENT TO DO
THIS, WHAT CAN HE NOT DO?
UNFETTERED POWER AND
CONSTITUTION SAID THAT WAS NOT
HIS JOB.
YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT THE SYSTEM
AND CHECKS AND BALANCES OF THE
JUDICIARY GETTING INVOLVED, LET
US NOT FORGET, MADISON AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WROTE THE
CONSTITUTION, UNDERSTOOD STATES
WERE ULTIMATE CHECK AND WOULD
GUARD LIBERTY AND RIGHT OF
CITIZENS AND THAT IS WHAT WE’RE
DOING.
THIS SHOULD BE ISSUE WHERE THERE
ARE 50 CHECKS ON PRESIDENT
BIDEN, ALL 50 STATES.
>> John: SEE IF THE ACLU TAKE